apparently I have not seen this yet this
is all something that's unfolding in
real time but I'm curious about the Bill
Belichick statement on Tom Brady oh and
and oh and oh something else that's
happened and this is something that I
think we have been flagging for a while
here Chris let's pivot let's go on plan
before we get back to Bill Belichick the
pelicans have given Cam Newton
permission to seek a trade which means
gonna find a trade which means he's
going to be gone Wow
well which is yes it does it means he's
gonna be gone which is gonna add another
wrinkle to you know maybe this Tom Brady
saga but man that's gonna be really
interesting and you know to me a little
interesting that is happening this late
in the game why wasn't this figured out
already you know we got some chairs
filled already as far as the quarterback
position and you just look at it right
now and go man what what out there is
gonna fit you know Cam Newton and his
skillset and who's gonna feel
comfortable with bringing him in right
now so man that's huge news but not
shocked I really thought Carolina would
move on from Cam Newton there started a
new era there and they're just trying to
get everybody new as far as that
leadership positions and the quarterback
position well and here's the key to to
the extent that the Chargers are in play
for Brady
the Chargers should be in play for Cam
Newton and this is the shot across the
bow to get the charges attention don't
go get Brady get Cam Newton because look
and you think about the master plan here
go ahead and take Tom Brady in Tampa Bay
we'll deal with Tom Brady we've beaten
Tom Brady in the past the Carolina
Panthers have we'd rather have Tom Brady
there then then Cam Newton ending up in
Tampa Bay if that's what the Buccaneers
end up doing so my point is get Cam
Newton out of the conference get him to
the Chargers get the charges attention
and work it out that way I still think
I've always thought that's where Cam
Newton needs to end up is with the LA
Chargers it's good for him and it's
great for the Chargers yeah I mean I
agree Mike I mean I know we're on the
same page there and just you know I
think as I told you last week you know I
was told by somebody I really trust and
in the NFL world
that there's no way the Chargers would
make a play for Cam Newton so maybe
that's changed I don't know but I was
told that by a pretty reliable source
that that wouldn't happen I don't know
the reasons for it either
because I'm like you to me it makes so
much sense and of course billboard
factor you know if it's physical checked
out is the guy that I still think and
played a very high level of beat
dominance that way and I just wonder
where this goes right now you know you
just know you know hey the Dolphins yeah
I don't know would they make a play the
Colts are they gonna get in this you
know he would fit perfectly what Matt
Nagy would want to do in Chicago and
that offense as far as some of the
movement stubs and all that but Chicago
is void of dry sticks a little bit to
really make this type of deal happen -
so man this is huge news I'm gonna be
amazing to watch this and here's another
thing as well Chris I don't know how the
hell anybody's going to do a physical on
Cam Newton we're gonna talk coming up
before we end this about the offseason
restrictions there is a huge doughnut
hole in the document as it relates to
physicals imposed on players who are the
subject of a trade we'll get to that
though coming up the Wonder Bread kids
as Ron Rivera talked with you know he's
the only coach that that Cam Newton has
ever known at the NFL level now if I'm
Ron Rivera I may have that same fatigue
that I think every Panthers fan has
about whether or not the guy's healthy
when Willie and healthy Willie stay
healthy so I don't know that Ron Rivera
wants to continue to live that but you
know it's an obvious connection and they
were together from 2011 through 2019 in
Carolina
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports